the girag an experience he's got to be
the hottest guy on Twitter him and John
McAfee that John McAfee guy who ran
around
oh yeah he's like halfway trolling
people it's hard to tell what he's doing
like what he's doing seems to be like
almost like a sum of it's very
theatrical
remember when we interviewed him when he
was on the run we interviewed him
remotely when he was on the run for
murder and he was saying that it was all
nonsense when I was asking him about
meth like how much Matthew really
smoking meth like I read an article that
showed that you had a meth lab that you
built in your backyard he's like if that
that was all fiction yeah it was like
that was a prank I was trolling people I
believe that you think so yeah I know
he's old-school he's old-school I mean
he was cooking it I mean he was
straight-up breaking bad in his backyard
where was even Belize like where was
summer something like that but someplace
where it all went sideways on him right
in his neighbor wind up getting murdered
that's why he was on the run right yeah
what a character the guy was a [ __ ]
anti-virus mogul you know I mean deaths
McAfee McAfee Antivirus who's they like
though it was like Norton and McAfee
those are the two big names in antivirus
under norton sub T right Mac if he's old
place and believe smoke is leftover meth
those dudes who [ __ ] escaped society
and go and move to some small island and
get some little little you know native
girlfriends that's a weird move right
that's a great move do you think you'd
ever see yourself doing that hell yes
you could podcast from an island
somewhere as soon as that's possible
being hologram stuff hologram style
anywhere that's winning like like you
could have you somebody on as a guest as
a podcast but in hologram form well
listen if we decided to set up a studio
like on an island somewhere and do the
podcast from an island somewhere and
we'd have to fly some guests in right
like say if there's a few of us we just
talk [ __ ] about the news all the things
that are going down the Trump
impeachment this and that we all did it
from an island somewhere and
occasionally we fly people in you put
say if you do it in unlined I write you
got you everybody flies in the
Four Seasons stay in a nice place has to
be somewhere where there's no hurricanes
less they don't get too many hurricanes
out heavily not like Jeffrey Epstein
pitch to get people on his plane come on
now we're just having a conversation
we're not banging any kids yeah I'm just
trying to black he's still alive anyway
so we can just go to his I do you think
he's still oh yeah really yeah he said
he's on that island how funny is it that
people just stop talking about the fact
that guy get whacked yeah yeah for sure
they whacked that guy I mean out of all
the things that I'm sure about that I
don't know and this is one that I'm most
or I'm most sure they murdered that guy
he knew so much from so many different
people and all the things that went
wrong even Michael Shermer who is like a
professional skeptic who doesn't believe
in anything he found out that the
cameras were broken and the the they
weren't working on the day the guy got
offed he's like oh maybe this is a
conspiracy uh you think you think the
guy Clinton flew to his [ __ ] Island
26 times he flew with Epstein why don't
he flew into his Island but he flew on
Epstein's jet 26 different time they
held El Chapo there for quite a quite a
long time and nothing happened to him
what at that same facility yeah like no
one had died there for 26 years or
something like that
consits of 90s until I heard they
whacked that guy the most hilarious
thing is you ever see who is cellmate
was that know this cellmate was a
[ __ ] gorilla real like the biggest
guy you could ever imagine being in your
cell like the guy looked like you're
like if you're gonna have a movie about
the worst possible cellmate you could
ever have it would be this guy look at
this guy look at the [ __ ] size of the
guy so glad he's white and he's a former
cop a former cop built like a brick
[ __ ]
I mean he's enormous what is that guy's
name Nicholas Turk toggle yeah yeah he
was a bad cop the cop went bad
but when you look at the size of him you
like come on man that's really his
cellmate look like before you went in
dog and that's him now yeah Wow
he's [ __ ] huge a huge gigantic
muscled up dude
was his cellmate and was he there when
he got offed no he wasn't there no what
a convenient there the first time that
he committed suicide
Oh tell me try outside yeah what Dave
Tim what did this Jim he killed four
people on a bad coke deal whoopsies
they had it come on big deal whatever
whatever a bad coke deal but how funny
is that that that's his cellmate like
what do we got what do we got well only
got a murderer that's built like a brick
[ __ ] let's put him in there with
him he got some wet cocaine he's
transferred out the eve of his suicide
okay
Vincent and then they had the doctor
picture with ghilane mask low at the in
and out and Studio City yeah it was just
like what they put that out disappeared
right made the news doctored photo
shopped for some reason where's that
lady
no one knows they didn't even know where
she was at the time and then she liked
that picture came out that thought she
was in Boston or something out about the
high-profile cases out of all of them
that's got to be the most strange right
this guy has an island on the island he
has a building that's colored in the the
the mate it's painted in the colours of
the Israeli flag they think he's a
Mossad agent he's some sort of
intelligence agent the reporter that
said that he was released earlier was
given a sweet deal because he was
intelligence that's not been verified
right right that came from one article
the Vanity Fair thing right he's on him
that got repeated a lot but I don't know
that we don't know if anywhere right
jeez it's the whole thing though Jesus
Christ what a crazy story
this is a strangest time because every
day there's new things coming at just so
hard and fast you can't keep up with it
this was his drone there's someone
flying a drone over his island every day
stop three weeks ago I guess but for the
like almost every day there was updated
drone footage for some reason I don't
know how this person was getting it
there they must have a boat oh yeah he
paid someone something like $50,000
sure to have a cement truck delivered
there a couple months before he got
arrested why I get a cement truck
shipped out to his Island and they think
that some [ __ ] got buried in that tunnel
or something I don't know Jesus says
I've been like that they have footage on
this island pre rate and post rate of
the FBI making it there yeah there was
one like last week or two weeks ago
where they supposedly saw him sitting in
again thought so it was just like a
worker from Islands there's gonna be so
many stories about this but we're never
gonna know it's gonna be one of those
things it's like the Kennedy
assassination or something we're decades
will go by you'll hear all these crazy
different stories people write books
about it but you'll never really know
exactly what happened hey we should get
the sign to this island what happens to
it how much you think an island cause
it's probably going to be cheap because
no one wants to live on how to fail
island so this could be the place Joe I
don't know if that's really smart it
doesn't seem like a good move it seems
like the one you want to buy you want to
do like what Roseanne did you get a
place on an island that is already
populated a bunch of nice people you
establish yourself as a valuable member
in the community and then you set up a
little camp there imagine the big island
the big island might be the move set up
a [ __ ] studio on the Big Island hell
yeah what do you think let's do it it's
not a bad idea right conservatory can we
do it up there where they let us know
they won't even let them build a new
house could tell us what if we take a
tent and a microphone up there no they
get mad at you you're littering
temporary no all right no you don't
wanna be up there anyways no air so
that's really a lot it's like only
11,000 square feet red Bambi blacking
out maybe we need to have something like
like near like Kona like where the Four
Seasons is see again the Four Seasons
bring oxygen I'm four seasons on oxygen
wants me a blend of the four seasons
you just we rent a suite at the Four
Seasons set it up as a studio yes that's
great we have to have an escape oxygen
like basement we can go to just in case
of our hurricane or something crazy
happens an oxygen base we already like
like an escape room we could we could
Airbnb it out to other podcasters that
need to make
not any water like your friends like a
good friend of yours [ __ ] that they
would ruin it maybe farm on our he's
gonna go there and fill it without the
seal on the water be broken yeah trust
me bad idea
[Applause]